dann gedacht okay er ist grad hier und
hier ich habe getroffen da dort dann
geht sein flug dann das andere zuhause
bericht drei stunden zurück so und so
lange brauchte für den flug zu
unterlagen für sachen packen bla bla bla
bla bla und ist mir dann hinterher
gelaufen hat mich geschockt ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge minecraft galaxy
mein herrchen hat sich doch gerade so
ein bisschen angehört noch im stimmbruch
aber dass die ganz einfach daran dass
ich ein bisschen der kälte binden und
der aufnahme im aufmerksamen zuschauer
wird erahnen können warum habe ich eine
andere sachen als in den letzten fünf
folgen bei craft galaxy dass ihr ganz
einfach daran dass ich aus dem urlaub
zurück bin ich bin ich beim
vorproduzieren diese folge ist live
heute aufgenommen um 14 uhr
ich werde gleich direkten upload packen
und ich habe mir einen neuen shader
runtergeladen das ganze zieht jetzt ein
bisschen idyllische aus und den hatte
ich auch schon manchmal in den sechs
folgen unschärfe shader wenn ich hierhin
cook ist dass der und scharf und wenn
ich da hin gucke dann ist der block
rechts neben mir ein bisschen unscharf
und alles mögliche finde ich so ein
bisschen cooler ich gehe mal ganz kurz
pen hier ich bin ja im orf des schinkens
das ganze gar nicht so gehe ich mal ganz
kurz kennen damit ihr das ganze über
tier dürfte abstimmen was für scheider
ich benutze ich finde ihn ganz cool ich
finde aber auch den den ich sonst mal
benutzt habt ganz cool
bei dem hier ist das ganze nicht so
flüssig aber ich finde das ganze ein
bisschen schöner weil es so ein bisschen
besser jetzt ist das zum beispiel hier
noch relativ dunkel weil die sonne
jedoch nicht aufgegangen ist weil die
sonne geht da hinten auf und bla bla bla
bla und ich muss jetzt noch ein bisschen
habe ich das hier schon voll gekleistert
mit glas ich glaube das hingekriegt oder
war oder war das irgendwie anders
ich frage mich immer noch ob malte ich
bin nicht mehr so richtig in der materie
hier gerade drin weil ich jetzt auch
schon sehr lange ich aufgenommen da und
hat ganz coole sachen gemacht das echt
schön da irgendwer so ein pool gefallen
weiß nicht recht schön aus hier das
passiert alles wird alles noch super
hier aber da unten das ist das ist eklig
dass hier so auch man dann ist noch
nicht mehr schön hier man solch eine
ganz ganz hier wieder die fledermaus
sich die blau hier sehe ich das jetzt
nur als fledermaus blau oder oder wie
ist das jetzt
das ist ja wenn ich mich beim kicken
verwandeln das blau wie sieht das denn
ist blau
das wäre und coole das alles bloß denkt
dann doch viel lieber mal den anderen
jetzt geht es wieder wenn ich wieder ich
bin es geht mir wieder zur fledermaus
jetzt ist wieder alles bläulich
jedenfalls hat die sonst immer die
shader
den hatte ich nicht von hand diese ganze
folge besteht daraus dass ich euch
irgendwie dass sich ein shader anstalt
bringen den shader hatte ich egal ich
spiele erst mit dem wir weiter ihr könnt
mir sagen woran das liegt wie an wie ich
das ganze um ändere oder irgendwie sowas
dann werde ich da mal schauen was sich
dann so machen lässt den ton machen wir
auch noch ein bisschen lauter so und
zwar viele leute interessiert hey warum
war denn jetzt so lange dass zum
beispiel gestern keine fakes kamen hatte
gestern ja genau das gestern keine fakes
covers soldaten oder was soll denn das
überhaupt hier mal sonntag keinen
kontakt haben uns was als meine tochter
kommt ja ich hatte geplant alles möglich
zu machen ich wollte auch richtig viel
filme im urlaub allerdings habe ich echt
meine kamera wirklich die ganze zeit
nahezu nie dabei gehabt weil ich bin so
ein mensch wenn ich im urlaub bin da
möchte ich den urlaub nicht dazu nutzen
dass ich da quasi trotzdem richtig viel
filme sondern dass das quasi einfach so
genieße ich bin besser genießen und
anderen ländern immer ja komm mach ein
foto von dieser sehenswürdigkeit oder so
aber ich bin mir also nee kommt lasst
uns das doch einfach mal erleben dass es
einfach mal auf sich wirken und jetzt
nicht so viele fotos davon machen
sondern einfach mal so entspannen und
das zu genießen was da so ist deswegen
hab ich alles nicht so viel gefilmt
nahezu gar nichts sondern nur auf der
hinfahrt habe ich was gefilmt ich bin
mit dem freund den urlaub gefahren und
auf der offen auf dem flugzeug habe ich
was gefilmt dann im urlaub habe ich gar
nichts gefühlt und auf dem rückflug habe
ich als gefilmt auf der rückfahrt habe
was gefilmt also sehr sehr wenig jetzt
war lang war sie wirklich einfach nur
einen roadtrip wirklich wieso ein
roadtrip halt also dass wir wirklich nur
den trip gefällt haben und nicht das
wirklich also nur die rot und nicht den
ganzen club das war es ein bisschen doof
und das ist für euch vielleicht auch ein
bisschen doof aber für mich war es ganz
schön leicht entspannen konnte aber
darum soll es gar nicht gehen ich wollte
nur sagen dass ich das ganze nicht
hochladen konnte weil das internet dort
hat ist mir nicht glaubt ich hatte eine
leitung die war so unterirdisch die wir
noch unterirdisch als man hier gerade zu
hause das ging ich gar nicht mehr fit
also die leitungen dort da hätte den
upload glaube ich 900 minuten gedauert
und ich habe es auch einmal probiert
dann was hochzuladen
also ich habe einfach mal sondern links
ich hab mir schon beginnt galaxy folge
mitgenommen die ich als war schon
hochgeladen hat damit wohl einfach
dadurch sehen wie lange der upload seger
dauert und die ist auch wirklich nach
zwei minuten direkt abgebrochen der
upload ich habe das wirklich nur
mitgenommen zu sehen okay wie schnell
wie lange häufig um sondern ganz normale
folge hier vielleicht hochzuladen sehr
sehr lange weil dann das fazit und
deswegen habe ich das einfach direkt
gelassen habe mir dann gedacht ok kommen
ich habe genug vorproduziert ihr habt
jeden tag ein video das ist ja schon mal
super es gab zeiten da gab es wirklich
noch wochenlang gar keine videos
deswegen war ich da schon sehr sehr
stolz auf mich aber für euch was
natürlich echt doof und das tut mir
dementsprechend auch leid aber ich kann
euch versichern dass jetzt heute kommt
er diese galaxie folge heute abend
kommen minecraft facts wenn ich total
verpennt
aber heute abend müssen doch die
minecraft facts kommen und da hat dann
all diese folge galaxy dir dann gerade
schaut und ich werde dann werde ich da
noch machen wieso war eigentlich kein
sand blog da unten das jetzt komisch und
ich werde bald auch eine einstündige
folge minecraft galaxy bringen ich denke
jetzt wahrscheinlich euro man sonst bist
du doch immer auf 15 minuten bleiben
irgendwie müssen wir irgendwie
beibehalten etwa 15 minuten machen und
nicht zu sehr über ziehen und so hat
alles ja klar nur es gibt diese regelung
es gibt ja manchmal leute die
live-streams machen da gibt's ein
komander krieger da gibt es ein paar
anderen die dann hier live streams von
diesem projekt machen die dann stunde
dauern
bei mir ist es allerdings so ihr kennt
mich im internet
ich kann keiner livestreams machen weil
man internet zu scheiße ist ganz
einfacher grund und daher gibt es die
möglichkeit für alle die was ich sehr
sehr sehr sehr cool finde die keinerlei
films machen können wo sind endlich
meine spaß ihre tiere
mehr oder sind des teams ich frag mich
wo beide sind sichere wasser
die ich eigentlich hier sind so ruben
systeme aber wir sind schon fackeln das
heißt er war schon jemand das ist ganz
cool für leute wie mich die wirklich ein
schlechtes internet haben und keiner
leistungs machen können nicht die chance
haben diese leistung zu machen ist es
ganz cool weil wir auch edward sich oben
auch alle hell oder wie er was soll denn
dort wohnt denn da der standard ich
würde mich sehr sehr schreibt immer wer
das ist wer wohnt denn da wird wer durch
leicht hat hier denn alles was sollte
mein cooler berg werden ich war doch von
anfang an den ersten folge schon drin
jetzt ist der ex ein anderer mann naja
gut egal
und hier ist einfach glas weggenommen
worden auch sehr schön
nicht weil der staat tue es auch weg
auch man das macht doch keinen spaß so
leute wenn wir alles geklaut wird
na ja gut ich war dann halt ich kann ich
kann nicht reden und bauen gleichzeitig
machen jetzt ist jetzt erst mal kurz
irgendein ziel was ich hier mache so ach
ich hab sogar noch palm und ein bisschen
habe ich einen stack halt so gekommen ok
sowie bei euch das ganze findet hier das
hier mache ich erstmal weg platsch
platsch platsch ganz blöden teile hier
das ist was niemand braucht da wollte
ich noch so stimmt dann muss noch diese
komischen lila bäume suchen ganz kurz
die folge geht doch gar nicht mehr allzu
lange da müsste eigentlich noch ein
bisschen was teil dieses komische laub
noch existiert wo habe ich dann wieder
bäume noch mal gehabt fand ich hier oben
auch noch da war noch was da ist auch
noch was ich will jetzt einfach mal ab
damit wir machen einen kleinen ausflug
in die sonne spieler unternehmen geht
ich kann ich keinerlei schutz machen
weil ich nicht so schlecht das internet
habe und deswegen gibt es eine
sonderregelung für alle diesen scheiß
internet haben und zwar dürfen die eine
einstündige folgen
zu bringen jetzt ist eure sache dass ihr
entscheiden dürfte wann ich diese
einstündige folge bringen soll
wahrscheinlich wird sie immer mal anders
sein also ich denke ich werde die folge
auf jeden fall nicht irgendwie am
sonntag montag dienstag machen weil da
lade ich ihr schon zwei videos pro tag
hoch also montags kommt ja zwei galaxy
aber ich finde es übrigens immer noch
sehr sehr cool muss ich echt sagen mit
diesem holz und diesem stein ich finde
es hat das hat irgendwie was soll so ein
bisschen loks ideal wollte ich mir auch
noch mitbringen weil ich dass ich jetzt
irgendwie verrückt also nicht das
abbauen aber geht nicht weg ist denn los
mit der war doch es ist halt wirklich so
dass wenn ich einen termin festlegen
würde wenn ich diese 1 stunden folge
bringen könnte dass ich den inhalten
werde
das ist bei mir immer so wenn ich
irgendwas festlegen beim leben ich werde
nie einhalten
deswegen möchte ich euch nur schon mal
sagen wenn ich irgendwann mal eine 1
stunden folge hochladen sollte dann wird
das ganze mit rechten dingen zugehen und
ihr müsst dann nicht denken höhe von
rund 1 stunden voll hoch dass es voller
regel nicht regelkonform andere machen
livestreams die eine stunde lang gehen
über dieses projekt wöchentlich und ich
darf dann halt eine folge hochladen
beziehungsweise nicht nur ich sondern
auch die anderen die kaller leistungs
machen ich darf dann halt eine folge
hochladen die halt einfach dann eine
stunde lang geht und ich werde dann eben
man hochladen über nacht oder wird die
irgendwann am tag kommen deswegen will
ich keinen richtigen tag festlegen ich
würde einfach mal grob sagen dass es
irgendwann zwischen mittwoch und samstag
kommt da kommt dann wöchentlich eine
einstündige folge und das wollte ich
damals gesagt so jetzt einmal ganz kurz
das ist eine organisatorische
geplätscher sache mein urlaub war
übrigens sehr schön ich wurde erkannt
viermal das aber alles dazu kommt wenn
ich heute in kontakt sein morgen kommt
der kontakt also heute sie kommt gerade
diese folge galaxy diergardt schaut dann
kommt nachher noch minecraft facts
morgen kommt wieder eine folge galaxy
annahmen
und abends kommt dann der kontakt mit so
ein paar ausschnitte und ein bisschen
dass ich über den urlaub quatsch wie das
ganze war das krasse ist ja immer also
ich mag es gar nicht wenn man erkannt
wird
ich mag es überhaupt nicht ich finde das
ist total nicht peinlich aber ich fühle
mich total unwohl wenn irgend jemand
sagt weißt du nicht kaum kraft da können
wir ein foto machen und so denke ich mir
mal so ok ja klar können wir das mal
also ich bin dann auch immer nett aber
ich bin immer so einer ich weiß nicht
ich mag das irgendwie nicht so wenn ich
so erkannt werde
10 habe ich ein zwei drei vier ich
brauch auf 10
ich mag das irgendwie gar nicht ich weiß
nicht woran das liegt aber ist halt
irgendwie so jeder hat er
unterschiedliche geschmäcker andere
würden das bestimmt super cool finden
arbeiten ich jetzt nicht so mein ding so
wo ist denn jetzt dieser komischen baum
ich schon vorbei geflogen da an den da
ist ja wahr oder sieht auch sehr schön
aus das sieht sehr sehr schön aus sehr
sehr schön schaut euch das mal an es ist
ja wunderschön aus ich möchte es einfach
nur ausleuchten weil schön aussieht
ich freue mich hin bauen möchte aber
einfach schön aussieht
das war an dass ich ja unglaublich schön
aus naja egal ich finds ja cool wenn ihr
mich erkennt aber wenn dann wirklich
leute mir er sich wurde ich weiß freitag
samstag sonntag montag dienstag weg das
in fünf tage ich wird vier mal erkannt
ich war an der nordsee und die sache ist
wenn ihr mich erkennt dann finde ich das
super und ihr müsst ja keine scheu haben
irgendwie anzusprechen allerdings haben
viel zu viele diese scheu und es war
wirklich teilweise so dass dann leute
ich war dann am strand oder war dann
wirklich leute die mir von dem von der
innenstadt bis zum strand hinterher
gefahren sind mit fahrrad die ganze zeit
wenn ich mich da mal umgedreht weil man
merkt dass ja wenn man verfolgt wird
die ganze zeit wenn ich mich dann
umgedreht habe kamen die dann irgendwie
an und haben dann immer wieder
weggeguckt oder so das war halt alles so
richtig das war wirklich schon so
stocker
das war halt ne richtig krass die habe
ich dann am ende doch angesprochen
als ich dann am strand saß als ich dann
in einem strandkorb mit meinen freunden
saß kam mir dann an haye könnte
vielleicht weil ich so ich hab mich die
ganze zeit verfolgt nämlich das zu
fragen hätte mich das nicht schon vorher
fragen können so zwar nett und so aber
weiß nicht das fand ich echt ein
bisschen komisch oder der ich mir also
leute wenn ihr mich seht her ich bin ein
mensch wie jeder andere auch ihr könnt
mich einfach auf der straße ansprechen
und nicht mehr hinterher rufen
konkret dreht man sich um dann ist auf
einmal keiner weil die dann irgendwie
weggelaufen sind oder so also ich weiß
ich das ist keine kritik an euch
es ist schon eine kritik aber es ist
jetzt nichts böses nicht böse gemeint da
könnten wir an unserer beziehung noch
ein wenig arbeiten wenig versteht was
ist jetzt noch irgendwo was hallo hab
ich aber ich habe ja schon drei
setzlinge verrate ich nicht immer
einfach zu zurück ich will jetzt auch
wohin hier spielt mal wieder zurück nach
hause
es ist zwar cool wenn man erkannt wird
das ist dann immer so krass ich ob meine
video so das ist schon krass vor allem
einer karmann der meinte ja ich kann
alle deine taten hat schon ist das was
ich suche
ich kenne alle der tat eine mega punkt
auswendig da kommt man echt sagen ja
simon unsere rolle kam nicht gerettet
als über diesem block house ich denke so
das wusste ich ja selbst nicht mal mehr
das war schon echt klasse den typen aber
total gefallen mit dem vor zehn minuten
lang unterhalten
aber das war echt cool und ich habe
immer noch gesagt ja ich flieg um 17 uhr
zurück allerdings das was der danach
gemacht hat fand ich einfach nur
beängstigend und zwar hat er dann
wirklich ausgerechnet ich habe mich ist
ja unfair dass ich in nrw wohnen gedacht
okay er ist gerade hier und hier ich
habe ihn nie getroffen und dann geht
sein flug dann erst an der zu hause drei
stunden zurück so und so lange brauchte
für den flug für unser land für sachen
packen
bla bla bla bla bla und ist mir dann
hinterher gelaufen hat mich geschockt
als ich dann zur kutsche gefahren bin
ach ja zukünftig gefallen als ich dann
zum flughafen gefahren bin
das ist richtig krass der kamen dann
hinterher gefahren also ja ich hab das
alles ausgerechnet wann du wo bist und
so da denkt man sich dann schon so wo
also ist es cool dass du meine videos
schaust aber lasst es dann auch bitte
dabei bleiben weil ich will nicht so
gestoppt werden und so das ist ich weiß
nicht also ich habe als ich dann das
vierte mal irgendwie wohl aberkannt
wurde habe ich dann gesehen dass dna
darüber auch schon video hochgeladen hat
wie es ist der kann zu werden habe ich
mir noch nicht angeguckt weil ich ja
sowas von schlecht internet hatte ich
muss vom server unter aber wer nämlich
erkennen dann sprecht mich an sagt hey
bist du mich luca machst du nicht videos
da sei ja klar oder näher kommt zu
machen aber mit sehr vielen leuten der
fotos gebracht aber nicht mehr 1000
jahre lang hinterherlaufen und dann erst
ansprechen und vor allem nicht stoppen
dass sie mir die ganze zeit hinterher
fahrt habe ich total angst wenn ich in
hamburg wohnen und mich sprechen da
leute an und die laufen dann die ganze
zeit hinterher und wissen danach wo ich
wohne da habe ich total angst vor
also das sind gründe das macht zwar
alles super spaß hier auf youtube aber
das sind so gründe warum das ganze
so ein bisschen nicht mehr so privat ist
ja nichts sich gezeigt hat dass ist ein
bisschen schade
na egal ich wollte ich gar nicht so viel
darüber reden weil das alles noch in
kontakt kommt wir sind auch schon wieder
bei 15 minuten 30 aber ich wollte
eigentlich noch den kommentar von mike
hanks dran neben der gemeint hat macht
die dinos sondern richtig cooles
tutorial geschickt wenn ich dann aber in
der nächsten folge machen morgen nach
ihr kommt es bei minecraft hektisch
jetzt noch was essen